all right the presidential campaign of
Ron DeSantis who is governor of Florida
is predicated on the idea that Florida
is great and that he will make America
like Florida there are all sorts of
Articles and discussions about this
Chauncey De Vega wrote a piece our
friend Chauncey uh in Salon called Ron
DeSantis wants to quote make America
Florida that's a dire threat the Trump
DeSantis race is a boon for the
mainstream media for the rest of us it's
an unmitigated disaster and indeed it is
true if the United States became like
Florida it would be a disaster now oh oh
my goodness hold on wait hold on but
David you go to Florida all the time
how can you go and say it would be bad
for the entire country to be like
Florida Florida's so bad why are you
going to Florida
I I go to Florida right with uh
the income I earn from my New York
business and with the security of my New
York health insurance knowing that I and
my family have our New York doctors and
New York infrastructure and access to
New York airports I go to Florida to go
to the beach for a week okay this is not
an endorsement of making the country
like Florida there are places in South
Carolina I've been to that are nice but
that doesn't mean South Carolina needs
to be the model for the United States
and when you look at Florida you see
okay it's 25th out of 50 on Health Care
in terms of quality access and cost it's
not a disaster but it's not a model to
be followed when you look at Health Care
in New York Connecticut Massachusetts
Etc Florida is 20th in infrastructure
all right it's not nearly the worst but
why would we say that's the
infrastructure your model we want to
follow Florida is 33rd in opportunity
26th on crime these aren't great numbers
they're very mediocre numbers they're
not great and they're not terrible but
it doesn't make a say the whole country
should be doing what Florida is doing
Florida also has something that
artificially makes it better in the
rankings than it otherwise would be
which is it has the benefit of money
earned in other states blue States
people from California and from
Washington and from Illinois and from
New York Connecticut Massachusetts who
say hey I'm going to go to Florida for
the weather or I'm going to retire in
Florida and so Florida is the
beneficiary of productivity and income
and money that comes from other states
if every state were like Florida all of
a sudden you lose that benefit you look
at covid DeSantis was quite Reckless
when it comes to the coveted pandemic
and he didn't Institute any meaningful
Public Health measures he in many cases
flouted them and as a result Florida's
coveted death rate we're talking per
capita now is the 10th highest in the
country DeSantis has been a staunch
opponent of Environmental Protection and
climate action and renewable energy if
you spread that to all 50 states it's a
disaster so the bottom line is that if
DeSantis was able to do to the country
what has happened in Florida it would be
very bad for the environment and it
would be very bad for our move towards
renewable energy the santis has been a
fierce advocate of voter suppression and
gerrymandering many states have made
great strides in those areas if DeSantis
had his way
all of that gets reversed he signed
bills that restrict voting rights
limiting mail-in ballots drop boxes
early voting hours he would try to do
that in every state
a vocal opponent of civil rights human
rights and women's rights he signed
bills that ban trans athletes from
participating in school sports limiting
abortion access preventing local
governments from passing
anti-discrimination ordinances this is
all an unmitigated disaster so Florida
can have nice beaches and restaurants
and primarily the liberal areas of
Florida if we're totally honest although
Pensacola is cool okay I will admit that
the state can still be something that we
would want to avoid the entire country
becoming and that is the only promise
that DeSantis is making it's where woke
goes to die and whatever else by the way
speaking of woke we're going to talk
about what's going on with Chick-fil-A
which relates to Florida in some
significant ways that'll be a little bit
later on in the show if you believe
that making the country like Florida
would be a good thing please contact me
info davidpackman.com with the data
skip the rhetoric skip the insults skip
the ad hominems skip the but David you
went to the beach in Miami give me the
data that tells us why making the
country like Florida would be a good
thing make sure you're subscribed to the
YouTube channel of course at youtube.com
slash the David Pacman show back right
after this short break